the Prime Minister and foreign secretary
have condemned the execution of a
British Iranian man in Iran State media
reported this morning that alireza
akbari has been executed after being
accused of working for British
intelligence here's our Middle East
correspondent Alistair bunkel
well the reports are from the mizen news
agency and that's quite important for
this reason they are closely linked to
the Iranian Judiciary and so therefore I
think we can I'm afraid assume that
these reports of his execution are
accurate and credible but what I would
say is also the statements from the
foreign sector in the Prime Minister
seem to suggest they are convinced that
this execution has gone ahead as well
now Ali Reza akbari held Jewel British
Iranian nationality he was a very senior
figure in the Iranian regime for many
years as the former deputy defense
minister it's a very high up in the
security echelons in Iran but was
arrested in 2019 by the Iranians accused
of spying for the British they said that
he received tens of thousands of pounds
in return for giving very valuable
evidence and intelligence to the British
the Iranians claim that he is one-off or
he has been one of
the most dangerous
um spies in Iran helping the West uh in
in many many years now these are all
accusations that he denies he says that
he was never a spy uh he never worked
for for the British and he's always held
that view except that in an interview
done earlier this week or a voice
recording that was done earlier this
week by him in his final days he did say
that he confessed to the allegations but
under severe torture from the Iranians
now there's been uh desperate attempts
by both the British and the Americans as
well the state department speaking out
about it in the last few days to try and
stop this execution happening uh
obviously the Iranians ignored those
please there have been a number of
political prisoners executed by the
Iranians in the last few weeks in
connection to the ongoing
anti-government protests that have been
taking place in Iran now this is not
directly linked to that however
Britain's response and very critical
response of the Iranian regime during
these protests has worsenal relations
between Britain and Iran and now we have
this the execution of a British Iranian
National
well in the last half an hour Alicia
Kearns the head of the Foreign Affairs
select committee joined in the
condemnation of Iran's regime
our hearts go out to all those who know
and love Ali razakbari But ultimately
this is the continuation of the
activities of a terrorist State we have
seen over the last few years
industrialization of Hostage taking by
Iran we have seen that they are
responsible for the most attempted
murders in the UK and the most
successful number of assassinations
across Western Europe they are
destabilizing whether it be in Ukraine
Iran Iraq their activities are heinous
and it's time unfortunate for us to
change our posture towards them
so how should the UK respond what should
the UK do diplomatically now do you
think
you saw an office because it is in
constant dialogue with Iran
Iran to deter Iran further from sort of
heinous acts we've seen today but there
are a number of options available so
I've been calling for a long time now
since the start of the uprising that
essentially after every state murder we
must stand by the protesters in Iran who
are just calling for an end-state
repression and put in place sanctions
against those responsible and supportive
of those State murders we can call in
and expel their charged Affair we can
recall our ambassador but two meaningful
things would be first of all to close
the Islamic revolutionary guard course
office in major Vale the leader of that
is directly appointed by the Supreme
Leader of Iran and that organization is
under investigation by the charity
commission and is responsible for the
spreading of the propaganda of the
Iranian regime and second in Parliament
this week voices were United that we
should prescribe the irgc and that would
be fundamental because it'd be a shift
to recognizing for the first time that
states can conduct terrorism but this is
a terrorist state
what across live to Westminster now and
speak to our political correspondent Rob
Powell so very strong condemnation there
from the chair of the Foreign Affairs
select committee Rob what other
political reaction has there been well
the response from the UK government Anna
has been Swift it's been strongly worded
and it's given the pretty clear
indication that those words at some
point will turn into action the Prime
Minister tweeted quite early this
morning saying that I'm appalled by the
execution of the British Iranian citizen
alireza akbari in Iran this was a callus
and cowardly act carried out by a
barbaric regime with no respect for the
human rights of their own people my
thoughts are with Ali rellis's family
friends and family we've also had a
statement from James cleverley the
foreign secretary saying the execution
of British Iranian Ali resurrect Bari is
a barbaric act that deserves
condemnation in the strongest possible
terms through this politically motivated
act the Iranian regime has once again
shown its callous disregard for human
life this will not stand unchallenged
and we will be summoning the Iranian
charged Affair to make clear our disgust
at Iran's actions our thoughts are with
Mr akbari's family now the charge Affair
is basically a senior senior Iranian
Diplomat um within the UK so the first
action will be that they will be hauled
into the foreign office for addressing
down I think reading into those
statements though and especially the
emphasis on this not going unchallenged
we can probably expect further action
from the UK government as well foreign
office sources say they won't preempt
that with specifics but clearly
listening to Alicia Keynes their toy MP
and a committee chair she thinks that
the options could include expelling that
senior Diplomat recalling the Ambassador
the UK ambassador from Tehran going
after an Islamic Center with links to
Iran in North London and even
prescribing the irgc the Revolutionary
guard Corps essentially one of the
hardest line parts of the established in
Tehran prescribing them as a terrorist
organization now the UK government says
it's also working to support Mr agbari's
family but I think it's pretty clear
reading into these statements that they
believe this execution is a politically
motivated act and as such it may well
provoke a quite significant diplomatic
Fallout